[Musique]
mon métier moi j'ai fait mes études
électriques informatiques
donc oui si je suis technicien
réparateur
ça s'est incliné mobile donc j'ai déjà
testé ces bons donc ménages en train de
nettoyer dans l'atelier de l'association
emmaüs
youssouf reparler petit électroménager
que l'on vient déposer et qui seront
ensuite remises en vente
né aux comores yusuf est atteint d'une
maladie génétique rare une maladie
orpheline comme on dit qui s'attaque aux
articulations à l'âge de 12 ans mais ce
moment là j'ai eu avec ma famille on
connaît rien pas mal au niveau des
genoux on m'a dit qu'ils ont coupé les
vaisseaux sanguins dont le ça n'arrête
pas de couler donc ils ont imputé
pendant quinze ans yusuf va marcher avec
des cannes puis en 2003 il rejoint
mayotte en kwassa kwassa et obtient sa
première prothèse
depuis dix ans il a rejoint la réunion
avec sa famille
ce midi comme tous les midis youssouf
rejoint la salle de prière du moufia
à cause de sa prothèse il fait la prière
assis sur une chaise
[Musique]
14h retour au boulot voici bernard
grondin le directeur d'emmaüs réunion
oui ça va oui ça avance ce matin j'ai
déjà fait un clean là j'ai déjà afin de
couleurs teintées la wii car le contrat
de youssouf va bientôt s'achever
depuis 2010 est le gouvernement a
fortement réduit les financements prévus
pour les contrats d'insertion pour
emmaüs réunion cela signifie la perte
d'un tiers de ses effectifs
quinze emplois sur 45 tu sais qu'on est
en difficulté
oui ça je sais tu sais que on aura du
mal à renouveler des contrats
d'insertion mais on est aujourd'hui dans
cette impossibilité de te dire mais là
on entre par la main à nouveau et on te
passe en cdi qui continue ta vie
monsieur délicieux en tout cas tout ce
numéro qu ils sont harada merci beaucoup
en fin d'après midi après sa journée de
travail
nous retrouvons youssouf chez lui au
centre de saint denis ah les cons c'est
ici c'est la maison d'accueil à ça c'est
là que c'est madame en train de préparer
à manger mon avis ou de fou à 14 ans il
souffre de la même maladie génétique que
son oncle et ses jambes porte les traces
des quatre opérations qu'il a déjà subie
ça c'est mon petit garçon mohamed anelka
anelka 7 ans lui a été opéré aux jambes
il ya quinze jours c'est ma fille malika
11 ans opérée elle oscille elles
marchent aujourd'hui avec d athènes
et voici mariam qui revient du lycée
avec béquilles et à ted c'est la nièce
et vient d'arriver
tous les enfants souffrent de la même
maladie génétique
c'est les samoussas
déjà sortait des photosites dans
quelques instants
ce sera l'heure de la rupture du jeûne
de ramadan mais avant de partager le
repas
youssouf va une nouvelle fois se rendre
à la mosquée comprend trois dates ça on
va manger parce qu'avant de fait la paix
est bon donc on doit au plus la gêne
d'un comprend trois dates je commence un
d'eux pendant le ramadan youssouf se
rend à la salle de prière cinq fois par
jour
cette fois il prend la direction de la
salle de prières de la rue montreuil
[Applaudissements]
l'appel du magazine indique qu'il est
l'heure de rentrer le jeune
[Musique]
même votre ordi
comme la le musée a déjà appelé donc on
doit couper
[Musique]
homo
m
selon l'équipe
avoue ne pas encore commencé c'est juste
toi qu'a mangé allait commencer à manger
[Musique]
vivez avec nous manger avec nous merci
de nous accueillir et tous les soirs on
s'assied comme ça en famille tous les
soirs de l'ama temps
la maladie dont souffrent les membres de
la famille a été baptisé syndrome des
abus du nom des neveux car ils sont à ce
jour les seuls connus à en être atteints
que les cinq enfants ont tous été opéré
à la réunion et ça ce sont des soins qui
nous a pas été possible comme un nom
même à mayotte
c'est ça qui a fait que j'ai récupéré
les neveux et nièces pour qu'ils ne
puissent pas avoir comme moi pour ne pas
être imputée puisque le plus dur mais
marc evolis et à des gens sûrs qu'ils
veulent pas s'asseoir à côté de toi
parce qu'ils étaient différents ou qui
veulent pas traîner avec toi parce que
tu es différent à des béquilles mais bon
j'ai de la chance d'avoir un canton
comme guy interdit qu'on veut ou trouve
que la force la force de tout gérer tout
ça il vient de ce que j'ai déjà vécu
même je mange mal la géorgie je dois
continuer à bosser pour que j'ai
toujours dernier quelque chose pour mes
enfants et ma famille pourquoi chaque
fois que je vois les enfants
ça me donne toujours de courage
[Musique]
ange gardien